ث انا جد الطفله هند حماده بطالب جميع
احرار العالم بطالب المؤسسات الدوليه
الصليب الاحمر هيئات حقوق الانسان بكشف
مصير حفيتي هند يعني كان مكان السبب يعني
بس ريحونا ريحوا قلوبنا ننا الناس لا
بننام ولا بناكل ولا بنشرب في قرص بارد في
بين الجثث لا ماكل لا مشرب خوف رعب الكلاب
بتنهش الجس بس قاعده اتقوا الله في هذه
الطفله يعني مصيره بس نعرف مصيرها ايا كان
المصير يعني يعني مش معقول العالم باسره
الا يوجد احرار في العالم الا يوجد شرفاء
في العالم اول اتصال اللي كانت بقول انا
جعانه بدي اكل بدي اشرب
عطشانه يعني تصور طفله اربع سنين لا اكل
ولا شرب من اول ساعه بتطلب الاكل والشرب
ايش حال صار فيها يعني في الحاله هذه
ارحمونا يعني وارحموا امها وارحموا
ابويا
ه